your personality should be something
that you design yourself you know that's
obviously the core argument the book is
that it can be a choice the research is
pretty clear that over time your
personality is going to change you as an
example are not the same person you were
five or ten years ago
Benjamin hottie in the building how are
you doing mine doing good happy to be
with you man really happy to be here
very happy to be with you talking about
personality today how do we define it
what is a personality well there's a lot
of different ways to look at it but I
think kind of the most surface level
just basic way of looking at it is that
it's your consistent attitudes and
behaviors you know just a person's
consistent way of being okay so the way
that you act in the world yeah well yeah
very much act you know and how you kind
of in your attitude such how you show up
regularly in situations okay
that seems pretty basic that doesn't
seem like there should be any debate
about what's going on with it
you know this is what you do that's your
personality okay so what are the biggest
myths about personality
one being that it's hardwired that it's
an eight that it can't change that the
best way to understand your personality
is by looking to the past and you know
which makes sense I mean if if you're
trying to understand who a person is
gonna be it makes sense to go and look
to the past and be like oh well that's
how that person's been so that's
probably how they're always gonna be
other kind of general views are that
it's something you can discover because
it's an eight because its viewed as
hardwired your your job is to discover
it and then once you've finally
discovered who you truly are then you
can finally go and create that life it's
tailor-made and fit perfectly for you
and you can find your perfect spouse and
perfect friends so it all fits nice and
neat and you don't have to go through
any change you're grinding you know just
your life will be perfect once you've
found that out just falls into place
exactly okay so if you're not or if
that's a myth if one of the myths is
that you discover your personality which
by the definition that we came up with
earlier on is the way that you act in
the world
if you don't discover that by looking
backwards how do you discover what your
personality is is there anything to
discover it depends on how you want to
look at it I think that there are things
you can learn about yourself without
question but ultimately your personality
should be something you decide you
design yourself you know that's
obviously the core I mean the book is
that it can be a choice the research is
pretty clear the over time your
personality is going to change you as an
example are not the same person you were
five or 10 years ago you know you're you
actually have changed even you've
actually probably changed more than you
think you have because we see the world
through the lens of our identity and so
we think we've actually probably changed
less than we actually have because we
see the world through through our
identity one one important crucial thing
here just to clarify is that identity
and personality are two different things
identity is how you define and describe
yourself it's your self-concept whereas
personality is how you consistently act
in the world
but your identity is way more important
your identity again is how you define
and describe yourself so if you said I'm
an introvert that's a statement about
your identity it may not actually be
true in fact
I would say it's not always true but
your your self-concept drives your
behavior and your behavior over time
becomes your personality and so a big
problem with identity is is that we we
get very fixated on our identity
you know we define ourselves certain
ways this is the type of person I am
it's it's shaped by the stories we tell
about ourselves and those stories are
usually either present based or past
based very rarely will you hear someone
talk about who they aspire to be well I
suppose
if you've got either overconfidence or
impostor syndrome you're either going to
under pitch or over pitch what you
presume that you will be in the future
right the uture so are we saying that
what most people do is take a couple of
traits or perhaps a few experiences a
few dispositions proclivities that they
have in the way that they operate within
the world and then drawing some much
grander conclusions from that and then
saying this is my personality and/or
identity that's a big one
yeah that has a lot to do with it yes we
we tend to really give a lot of weight
to various instances some of them could
have been traumatic as an example you
know but we give we give weight to a lot
of former experiences and those former
experiences shape how we see the world
so for example if you failed a math test
and it was just you know it wasn't that
great for you you may then just say that
that one instance really improves that
you can't do math so therefore that is
not something you can do you know you
have a bad experience giving a speech in
front of a class you're therefore you
can't be someone who could be good at
speaking we tend to define ourselves
very strongly by former experiences
particularly the negative ones and then
we tend to avoid those negative
experiences and try to find something
that feels a little easier your comfort
zone and your personality are very
similar concepts
I would actually lump them into a very
similar category where you do what's
comfortable and you don't do what's
uncomfortable and to step outside your
comfort zone would be to probably act
outside of your way of typically doing
things but that's where obviously growth
and learning are and that's where new
experiences are that's where change is
just as one other quick example like are
our two twins I've got two 18 month old
girls we live in Florida where there's a
lot of swimming pools so we're having
our two girls do swimming lessons right
first several times you put them in the
swimming pool these two little gross who
can't even talk you know it's pretty
tough they're screaming they're yelling
a month and a half two months later
these girls are freaking amazing
swimmers yeah
the question is those as adults how
often do we put ourselves into such
immersive learning experiences we
stopped doing that over time because
often as people get older they they stop
wanting to deal with such emotional
learning experiences they prefer to be
able to predict
the outcomes of their behavior so they
don't want to put themselves into
situations that are unpredictable or
difficult or challenging or emotionally
stimulating yeah I I find it interesting
how it relates to the comfort zone thing
that you're it's kind of a little bit
like putting the cart before the horse
or putting the horse before the cart
here right that the actions that you
tend toward are restricted by your own
view of your own identity and your
personality which further drills you
into that particular pigeonhole I am the
person who is bad at maths therefore
I'll always let the friend get the bill
or whatever because that's how I
self-identify which then makes you
cyclically makes you worsen exactly no
it's true it's what's it what's
interesting about identity if you think
about how people define and describe
themselves identity feels very sacred
and personal and so because it's your
identity you seek to defend it and to
confirm it so if you're telling someone
you're bad at math you're actually gonna
try to confirm that by proving that
you're but how about it math I am yeah
yeah exactly like and and so we're very
we we really like to define define our
current identity what's so there's a
really good TED talk by Daniel Gilbert
he's at Harvard he gave a TED talk
called the psychology of your future
self have you seen that one No ten
minutes long actually it's less it's
like seven minutes long I will really
worry I will link it in the show notes
below Daniel Gil watch yeah yeah Daniel
Gilbert psychology of your future self
but here's why it's so interesting so
what Gilbert does is he asks people do
you think you're the same person you
were ten years ago almost everyone says
no but then what he does is he asks
people do you think you're gonna be the
same person in ten years from now and
most people say yes that's such a big
red pill to swallow oh yeah so here's
yeah it is a big red pill so here's why
it's so crazy man is that he calls at
the end of history illusion you can
reference that below if you want any
research stays on it but basically what
he says and this is Gilbert's exact
quote human beings are works in progress
that mistakenly think they're finished
and so the reason why and he explains
why he says the reason people don't
adequately predict their future is not
because they can't but because they
don't we spent we we often default
as people to the past we default to our
memory because it's a lot easier to
remember the past than to imagine the
future and so we don't spend very much
time adequately thinking about who our
future self is going to be and so as a
result we make a lot of decisions here
and now assuming that the decisions our
future stuff would be happy about such
as getting a tattoo I'm just giving us
an example because I see it when I arm
but like we make decisions here now oh
did you not have one oh I thought I saw
one you know that you know what I saw is
I saw your shirt don't say that my mum
listens to this podcast if she finds out
I've got a tattoo I don't mum don't
listen to him he's lying a promise
basically what Gilbert talks about is
that people make decisions in the
present that their future selves are
really angry about for example getting
way out of shape yeah you know what I
mean like and so there's another
researcher his name is Hal Hirschfeld
he's at UCLA and he studies how having a
clear future self-concept allows you to
make better decisions in the present
because what you want to do just as you
view your former self as a different
person it's good for identity and also
just for behavior to view your future
self as a totally different person than
you you in like three to five years from
now is gonna have different perspectives
you might be in a totally different
situation you might not be podcasting
knows what you're gonna be up to except
for you if you decide who you want to be
in the future but like your future self
is gonna have different perspectives you
can be in a different situation gonna be
solving different problems and you'll
learn you'll know things that you
currently don't know which is gonna
alter how you go about doing things
that's totally fair and fine I actually
hope my future self is a lot smarter
than I am today and makes better
decisions and stuff but if you view your
future self as a different person and
this is what how Hirschfeld said then
you can start thinking about what would
they prefer versus what would I prefer
because right now I might prefer just to
go sit on the couch and eat doughnuts
all day like you know I've got five kids
so like sometimes I'll go home from work
and I'll be fried and my kids like want
to play in the current version of been
hard he doesn't want to anything I want
to go something look at YouTube but if I
think about what would my future self
want then I can make decisions based on
what my future self would want and one
other quick thought is that have you
ever heard of the concept of deliberate
practice no so have you ever heard of
the 10,000 hour rule by Malcolm Gladwell
yes
so Gladwell stole that idea from the
research on what's called deliberate
practice there actually is no 10,000
rule you could do something for 10,000
hours and continue to suck at it but
what deliberate practice means is that
you're doing something in a very
intentional way towards a very specific
goal so you have to have a clear future
self in order to engage in a specific
type of learning like if you saw
yourself as a certain type of podcast or
you could then adjust your skills to get
to that level right like your and but if
you didn't have a goal then it doesn't
really matter what you do and so the
process is always shaped by the goal and
in order to engage in meaningful
learning you have to have a clear future
self is the goal a projection of the
person you want to be in in many ways
yes it would have to do if outcomes
you're seeking it would have but yeah in
this case it would be who is your future
self what is their circumstances their
you know who are they what is their life
like you know you could get as details
one how much money are they making how
many podcasts you know downloads they
have like what where do you live what
are your relationships like it's getting
really clear on your future self but so
yeah I mean that's that's part of you
could obviously think in terms of
outcomes as well I mean you know the
process of getting 250 million downloads
I'm sure is different than the process
of getting to 2,000 downloads you know
and so you know Joe Rogan know if you
Joe Rogan making those bags with Spotify
but yeah it's it's interesting
James clear anatomic habits references
something similar to this when he talks
about habit change and he uses a analogy
of identity based change that's actually
what he calls it I think in atomic
habits where where he says there's
something that is agree with James on
but that one is smart yeah
what else was I thinking about I was
thinking about something to do with this
recently it'll come to me it'll come
back to me anyway
you dropped a star in the book that says
90% of people are dissatisfied with some
aspect of their personality that that is
it's just such a crazy statistic to hear
it's like the vast vast majority of
people have some malignant part of their
own psyche that they want to get rid of
oh you don't need to go that far I mean
basically we all might want to make
changes maybe I want to be a little bit
more patient maybe I want to be more
empathetic maybe I want to be more
charismatic maybe I want to be more
organized you know maybe I want to be
more bold maybe I want to be more
confident so I mean there's aspects of
all of us that we want to change and
improve maybe I want to you know and so
yeah we all have aspects of ourselves
maybe I ought to be more creative so
there's aspects of ourselves that we all
want to change okay
I get that I want to get into some
slightly more esoteric questions here
before we get on to potentially how can
people utilize what you've discovered to
improve themselves
how does personality relate to who the
true
you is right so let's say did talked
about this on a live stream yesterday if
you get a nose job if you get plastic
surgery on your nose is it still your
nose most people will be like well yeah
it's kind of your nose but it's also
kind of not your nose it's not how your
nose would have been how do you not have
had the surgery and I think sometimes
when we look at behavior change
especially when we're talking about
quite fundamental behavior change which
is identity personality the fundamental
like axioms of how we see the world and
how we operate within the world like how
does personality relate to who the true
you is does that make sense
mm-hmm yeah so personality is more
surface level you know personality is a
byproduct of identity of situations
personality can even be a byproduct of
trauma you know there's actually a quote
from Gabor Ma Tei have you ever heard of
Gabor Monte so yeah he's got a quote
where he says what we call the
personality is often basically some
genuine traits or coping mechanisms that
are not actually the true you but are
actually the absence of the true you you
know and we've seen this where people we
become a certain way because of life or
our situation or the environment or
kovin 19 and maybe that has nothing to
do with who we really are but yeah I
think true you goes to more of a like
that's more of an X
existential question or maybe even a
spiritual question from my perspective
true.you it has a lot to do with
decision making choices attention you
know wherever you dry your you know
could even have to do with consciousness
but like it's where you draw your
attention it's your ability to make
choices to choose to you know to make
decisions that's more fundamental than
just whatever you are right now because
who you are right now is different from
who you were when you were 10 years old
you know so how you're represented in
the outside world is not the full
picture
so your personality in a very real sense
is actually your capacity to make
choices to change your personality would
that be one way to think about it I
wouldn't say this personality I mean you
could you could use a different word
personality I would rather use I mean
each personality is just how you show up
you know actually the word comes from
persona like which is back in the day
was a compute as a mask you know like
you have a different mask in different
situations like Shakespeare said all the
world's a stage and all of us come and
go we've got different roles that we
play right yeah so right now you're a
podcaster in one situation you might be
you know I'm gonna go home and I'm gonna
go be a dad you know
dominoes on podcast mouse goes off yeah
to some degree I mean I'm in a different
role I'm still me it's not like I'm
pretending to be someone different I'm
just in a different situation and if you
actually followed me in all those
situations I wouldn't actually be the
exact same dude in every situation you
know like I've got to actually be a
little different from context to context
you know from situation to situation so
yeah I think what itwhat yeah so
personality is just how you're showing
up okay Larry temporary let's talk about
personality tests I've got a story from
last year let's hear it I was speaking
to a girl so it's slightly well slightly
well known girl and before we started
getting even close to serious she made
me take a big five personality test she
had you take the big five yeah cool wait
what happened I I've done it a number of
times before took the test sent it to
her because I just thought oh this is
funny I was like you do it as well you
take it as well cuz I want to see what
yours are and I already knew what my
results would be it actually had moved a
little bit from the last time but I knew
what my results would be and that that
apparently passed whatever particular
criteria she'd had for someone that she
was sort of speaking to and she had a
fairly good justification
we can get into the accuracy of
personality tests in a second but her
justification was it's a very expedient
way to work out what sort of person
someone is and as someone that likes he
likes efficiency I actually found it I
found it interesting I wasn't too sure
what it meant about her worldview but I
actually found it quite quite an
interesting way to kind of begin a
dialogue deal with her know so it didn't
work didn't work didn't work no but I
didn't predict success in their
relationship did not it did not all know
can you tell us I'm gonna give her
credit I'm gonna give her any give her
huge kudos though cuz the big five is
actually a better way of looking at
personality big five is more of a
scientific way of looking at personality
so you got and I wasn't I'm not actually
sure which test you took you know
because there's a lot of them on the big
five but on that test you'd be you'd got
you'd give a score on on the five right
one out of a hundred right correct so
you got a score one I have a hundred on
introversion versus extraversion you
would never actually be called an
introvert or an extrovert you just say
that I'm like a 36 on the scale or
something right X percentile that's the
key that is the key is that the research
on big five shows that in different
situations you're going to be a little
different it's going to change over time
no matter what big five good for your
fat lady because that's that's the best
way of looking at personality most of
the tests are not like that most of the
tests because because the big five
didn't give you a type did it did it
tell you what type of person you were
no it just says you are this percentile
in agreeableness percentile in most
tests that are non scientific like the
myers-briggs of the world the ideograms
the disks they wouldn't give you
percentile ranks what they would do is
they'd give you a type they'd say you're
an ENFJ or you're a six or you're a blue
and so type based personality tests are
garbage they're not good science that's
not how you view personality to radical
because there's no such thing as a
person
Alley tape
here's why here's why well think about
it if I were to just say you're an
extrovert which you may or may not be
would that always be true probably not
no in some situations you're not going
to be in some situation and I'm not
saying I don't actually know it you'd be
I would not actually give you a
categorization but these they they're
over simplifications but also
personality doesn't work in types
personalities a lot more contextual it
also changes from one situation to
another so like it has a lot to do with
situations and environments and people
year around and mood you're in you know
like it's and also it does change over
time what the type based tests do and
they're just not a valid way of
measuring personality because it doesn't
really look that way but these tests
what they do is they give you a really
strong sense of identity we talked about
identity so like member if I if I get a
type that I'm a six according to the
India gram then I think I'm always a six
which is not true it creates tunnel
vision because now I have this strong
sense of identity which is now gonna
predict my behavior and actually maybe
create my personality but then I defend
it I defend my identity I defend my six
you're absolutely killing me I've got
written down here just identity tests
not personality tests dude I've got
written down here let's talk about
personality tests and I've got a little
cue to remind me about my story from
last year and then just below it I've
got written horoscopes because to me
it's the same as that you know like it
is so the less the less
rounded intellectual version of the girl
who gave me the big five with extreme
salt but let's criticize Big Five in a
second but the less well worldly rounded
version of the girl that gave me that is
the same one that says what star sign
are you
and then goes oh yeah that's that's so
typical you use you're such an asparagus
you know like you such a you such a
you're such a Clement it's like I can't
I could just I can you know I just
totally can't you know what what's the
next step of that it was the next one
oh you're black you can't go to my
school any different from racism its
birth racism birth racism that's what it
is I can't I can't be with Pi see I
can't be with a Pisces because I'm just
such a I'm totally a Gemini and it we we
just we wouldn't gel you know it's funny
about that
so when so so there's a big so a big big
idea in psychology which is relevant to
learning is what's called psychological
flexibility really key what
psychological flexibility means that you
can handle your emotions especially when
you're going through like extreme change
you know if you're in a new situation
and you're dealing with stress you got
to be flexible to your emotions to the
situation and to be able to handle it
that's actually how you build confidence
and confidence means you can handle
things what's funny about what you're
describing is like you know he's a
Pisces I'm a Capricorn there's no way I
could be in a relationship with him like
that is like the exact that's that's
what we would call psychological
rigidity like you are so rigid and so
fixed in your mind it's essentially a
fixed mindset you're saying I can't
handle that
I can't be flexible to that you know
like I I can only fit myself to various
types of people and I've got to find
those perfect fits because I'm fixed and
I can't change and I and you can't
expect me to do anything outside of what
my my horoscope tells me I am it's like
I don't know what is it let's go down
this rabbit hole cuz I've never spoken
about before
what is it about horoscopes and girls
man like what is it is it is it like I
don't know I've never met one except for
my mom who loves them my mom loves them
as well
my mom absolutely adores them but now I
know dude I know loads of girls tons of
girl is it people just trying to bring
order to chaos is it them just trying to
have some way of feeling like that in
understanding with the world on a level
with what's going on I don't know man I
mean I'm a Capricorn but I think they
actually changed the signs your flick
literally your kids no they change that
you remember your capri code membership
got revoked I think I might be in a
different category or at least the
people around me tit because they
digested it by like ten days and so like
like a third of the population sign
change and so they had to have like an
identity crisis for a minute so how do
you know had you been single you would
have had to have gone back to all of the
girls that said I I'm AB Gemini I can't
be with Capricorn my Capricorn cards
gone away I'm now like a total I'm
totally a Leo and you're an asparagus
but yeah okay so um horoscopes in a very
real way are the reason that we can
laugh about them and make them silly is
that we don't believe some people me
included don't believe that there is any
validity to the implication of the date
that you were born on or the position of
the stars upon your birth impacting the
kind of person that you are how much
truth is there in myers-briggs or
whatever obviously it's very rough-hewn
it's boxing you into a kind of a
pejorative term or majority term or
whatever it would be a category but is
there anything like are they even close
to the mark are you more a six than you
are a 1 are you more a red than you are
a blue maybe in the moment
maybe various contexts a lot of it has
to do with the mindset you had when you
took the test you know just as an
example like there's a lot of research
where they'll test how people score on
these tests based on the conditions
they're in so like as an example one
study it took the participants and broke
them into two groups and they had
group number one take the a personality
test and a week later they took the same
test okay just to see how they would
score yep and in that situation it was
the same test administrator it was
someone there gave them the tests you
know the same person gave them the test
both times and they got fairly similar
scores the other group same situation
took the test
a week later took the same test the only
difference was there was two separate
test administrators and by making that
one change the scores were all
completely unrelated and so yeah you
know I think that yes you know when I
think about the test that really hosed
me because I tell the story in the
beginning of the book about the color
code about how my wife almost didn't
marry me because of my score on that
test when I think about the score that I
had at the time cuz that was me in
college eight years ago I took the test
and my wife and her family who took the
two personality tests the color code
very seriously the like oh shoot this
guy's a white Lauren you can't marry
this white because it's a passive aloof
dreamer and they were all Reds which are
type-a go-getters um if I think about
myself just in that situation am i more
of a white that I'm a yellow or am I
more you know like because according to
that test there's only four categories
of people either you're a red which is a
type a go-getter you're a blue which
means you really are into relationships
your hearts and your white which means
you're a passive aloof dreamer you know
very introverted maybe and then if
you're a yellow you're just a pure
extrovert you know and so if I actually
think about
just me in the one snapshot of time back
at that time when I was considered a a
white according to Lawrence family if I
were to say am i more white than I am a
blue or yellow maybe I really don't know
man like I there were sides of me that
were very driven you know there were
sides me where I really liked
relationships but there was a lot of me
that really liked thinking and
reflecting which obviously still is a
big part of me because we're having
these conversations about thinking in
psychology and stuff but I wasn't I
would have never can't categorize myself
that way even five years before that
like before I got really into psychology
I was more into like gaming and like
more into like snowboarding and like
being with friends and so like that
changed a lot because I went on that
church mission which really changed my
life a lot and even now I would say I'm
I would actually mean my wife retook the
test because we got asked to do it she
was the red according to the test back
in the day and I was a white but when we
took the test I got yellow and she got
white and so I don't know man I do think
that you can get some ideas from it
here's what most people say they get out
of the tests is that it shows them the
areas where they should better like
they're clear weaknesses um and I think
the reason it does that is this think
about it if there's only like four
categories if I know that you're either
gonna be if you're a white as an example
on the color code which means you're
very passive you're very thoughtful you
spend a lot of time in your head then I
know that your weaknesses are probably
that you're you don't talk very much in
social situations and so I can lay out a
bunch of prescriptions about you that
are very general that you're gonna
adhere and you have holy crap that it's
exactly me that's you know it's like
it's the horoscopes all over again
yeah it's just laying out you know
prescription so if you're a drip typing
personality then I can come up with a
couple prescriptions and say probably
someone who doesn't doesn't do very good
when someone tells you what to do you
know and I can just lay out very general
prescriptions you know you should be a
medium you could be one of those is
there a Jonathan in the room I'm getting
at you I'm getting at Jonathan's is
there I'm sensing I'm sensing that
there's a part of you a part of your
personality that you're not
you happy with at the moment I could see
you doing that televangelists stuff
that'd be real funny um okay so there is
some use to understanding where your
strengths and weaknesses lie but is a
personality test the best way to go
about that is there another way to do it
can we just like reflect iteratively
reflect on the way that we operate day
to day I mean I'd ask you have you will
let's just say either decided honed
figured out the strengths and weaknesses
that you either like to develop or not
develop and is there a way that you've
done it a lot of introspective work a
lot reflection three and a bit years a
consistent meditation practice with
meditation coach a lot of daily
journaling I've got so what you've just
described is enormous ly more valuable
than anything you would ever get from a
personality test yeah
meditation journaling also decision
making yeah so journaling obviously
about your past and present
you know journaling about who you want
to be journal about what you're dealing
with that is such an incredible what I
would consider an emotional regulation
tool you know it allows you to be clear
on your emotions to get them picture it
allows you to choose the meanings that
you give to your former experiences it
allows you to think very clearly about
who you want to be it gives you space to
think reflect meditate so yeah that that
is a much better place of understanding
who you are and what you're dealing with
and also integrating you know just as an
example you know we all have strengths
and weaknesses we all have a personality
I'm not declining that but what you know
the extent to which that's fluid or
flexible in many ways is up to our own
practices such as meditation you know
what I mean and so as an example my one
of my son's you know because we adopted
three from the foster system we he's
semi extreme sometimes when he's with
his friends you know like he'll
sometimes like throw like a little
emotional outburst and that's what I
literally happened yesterday so one of
our neighbors was over and they were
swimming in our backyard a son who's
eight years old started kind of freaking
out a little bit and so our neighbor
left
who like he was just like I'm not
hanging out with you screw this he
peaced out and so then my son was all
mad because his friend left and we're
like well what happened he was like well
he was talking I was saying blah blah
blah like he was being rude
you know and but he was sad that the
friend left and then we kicked him out
of the pool because he was being a jerk
and so I'm like alright you got to pull
out your journal and this is about an
hour about thirty minutes later I hold
you so eight years old and I said just
write because this was after he got
kicked out of the pool and he was pretty
bummed out news feel sad and usually
when we're sad we we suppress it we
don't we don't clear it up you know and
what the way to clear it up so what
Viktor Frankl said and man search for me
have you ever read that one yeah dude
isn't that killer Oh bro let me inject
that before you go on and tell us what
you don't know interject The Forgotten
Highlander by Alistair Eckhart
I'll read it bro never read it bro okay
oh great days
remove all of the psychology remove the
the understanding and and kind of the
that transparency that Franco brings to
it where he's actually able to see
what's going on but just take his
experience and turn it up to eleven for
about six years dude
I'll leave me we got in Highlander
forgotten tiling about Alistair okay
yeah it'll take your head off so good so
good okay well so let me just give two
quick for uncle insights and then I'll
go back to my son
please insight number one and this is
goes to my son is that emotion ceases to
be suffering the minute you give a clear
picture of it
what's up me emotion ceases to be
suffering when you give a clear picture
of it you give a clear picture to your
emotions by turning them into words so
for example if you write about and it
turned into a story so my son was
feeling sad and overwhelmed and I said
write about what happened well I was
swimming in the backyard with Rowan and
I was being a jerk to him and then he
left
and now I feel bad because I got kicked
out of pool now we have a picture of it
oh so that's what happened and this is
why you don't feel very good
what should we do about it like how do
you feel because this happened I don't
feel very good about it I feel pretty
bummed what else do you feel well I'm
sad that I made Rowan leave because I
wish I was out there swimming with him
and now I got kicked out of pool okay
well what do you want to do about this
you know do you want to swim with Rowan
in the future do you want to have good
experiences in the future yeah so what
needs to happen you do need to do
anything to Rowan you need to apologize
you know this is like literally turning
emotions into a picture so that you can
then know what to do with it so it's
less overwhelming the problem is is that
a lot of people they don't have an
emotional regulation technique so they
can get clear
the other thing Franco said real quick
I'll just throw this out there but then
we can continue forward is that Franco
said that the own you know at the moment
a person loses hope and purpose for
their future the present becomes
meaningless and as a result the
suffering and the present becomes
unbearable so if you're in the freakin
Holocaust what that means is you die you
you lose hope in the future you died in
the Holocaust you know that's why he
said that circumcised a said
circumstances he said life is not
unbearable by circumstance it's it's
unbearable by having a lack of meaning
and purpose for your life and so he said
you have to have a hope and meaning for
your future in order to actually have a
healthy present you can't live in the
present without a future and that makes
so much sense when you think about how
Hersh fields research on future self in
making decisions based on what your
future self would want you can't make
good decisions in the present without
having a quality future to work towards
Frankel said that so anyways yeah but
the only reason I brought up my son with
you and journaling is the journaling and
meditation and decision-making and
moving forward setting goals moving
forward learning those are the best ways
that you're gonna learn about yourself
are those things you know to make the
big full I have
I mean learning is I don't know if
there's a big for you know I just
wondered if this so if we were to say if
I was to say to you what some of the
tools that you would say to someone okay
I I believe you dr. hardy I have faith
that you're not horoscope televangelist
man
I believe that I can impact my not only
my personality but also my identity
through my personality and the actions
that I've taken the decisions that I
make what should I do on my first step
toward becoming less fixed toward
removing the weaknesses that I have in
the holes in my game and then impacting
on my strengths what would you say
genius man just just as a quick form of
clarification it's actually your your
personality works through your identity
not the other way around
you choose your identity first yeah
which is how you define it to subscribe
yourself and then that your identity or
your self-concept shapes your behavior
which over time becomes your personality
yes I am going to get by the end of this
podcast I am going to get my head around
it in my defense this is quite I'm sure
that everybody that's listening is
thinking the same like this is so kind
of ground shaking it's very contrary to
the narrative that we've been told for a
long time so do you feel like this is
ground shaking what I'm telling you a
little bit very much so I mean if I
hadn't cut the cheek
to reading the book right like it's like
knowing the end of the movie before what
but it's very different hearing it
spoken to you and again I just man I
just keep on getting read pilled on my
show Greg McEwan came on and read billed
me about essentialism and just made me
look at ol fool like about like why are
you doing this and why are you doing
that and why are you doing this I'm like
this is this is my show stop it and it's
the same with this I'm just like okay
okay get your head around it get you can
make this work you can done so did your
awesome finest shows I've been on hey
you heard a new first lady's and Chad
you can use that all day you can just we
can loop that I've got it I've got I've
got dr. Jordan Peterson great
conversations with some of my good
friends dr. hardy one of the most fun
shows that I've ever been on that's it
that's it where's my hundred million
deal Spotify coming to me let's give you
a hundred million that's it thank you
okay so um I'll give you I'll give you
the steps now yes yes please we've
really we've really cleared the clutter
one last idea before we give the steps
in that to this and I've already kind of
said it but your current identity needs
to be held loosely that's why you
wouldn't want to overly label yourself
if you want to give yourself a label
like I'm a podcaster because that leads
to your goals that's fine but hold your
current identity loosely because you're
not the same person you are in the past
and you're not gonna be the same person
in the future so rather than being so
definitive in who you are right now
recognize that who you are right now
doesn't really matter that's actually
what Carol Dweck says Carol Dweck she's
done all of her work on growth mindset
first fixed mindset and the people with
a fixed mindset are very defined by the
now if you get an F on the test as a
student that means oh crap I'm dumb if
you get an F with a growth mindset you
say I'm not there yet I can get smarter
so you're never defined by the now if
you have a growth mindset if you have a
fixed mindset then who you are today is
all you'll ever be is that so coming
from someone who knows his salt right
who understands whether on about that
I've read Carol Dweck's
mindset and thought they're all do acts
work is some of the best in psychology
legit she is incredibly legit her work
is so high-quality she's a Stanford
psychologist she's been studying this
step for decades her work is some of the
absolute
best in psychology who else is up the
let's before we move on before we get
Ellen Langer Ellen Langer at Harvard I
would point to her work read her books
minds to her book mindfulness and
counterclockwise will blow your mind
well they'll give you a few ready to put
put in the show notes tell me that yeah
Ellen Langer her look mindfulness Langer
LAN ger she's at Harvard yep mindfulness
and counterclockwise are her books
I like Daniel Gilbert as I've described
already he's the guy who did the future
self stuff those are a Brent's life is
another really good one Brent's life's
got some crazy work he actually wrote a
book called time and psychological
explanation
that's very dense academic but it
changes everything about how you view
time oh God
have you read carlo rovelli x' book oh
let me check salt I've got to hear
weather weather here it is cold the
order of time and if you get this on
audible people that are listening if you
get this one audible or you dr. hardy
it's read by Benedict Cumberbatch it's
read by dr. strange and it's I mean you
can see there that's how it's super
small real small only what's this how
many pages 108 185 pages of like a five
paper it's tiny super quick read but
benedict cumberbatch man audible get
that's your next audible credit there
everyone that's listening go and do it I
just bought it
[Laughter]
dude it's it's done it's real cool okay
look we are this is just a conversation
between me and you now I mean you've got
this bromance going on we've forgotten
that we're doing a podcast everyone's
like look guys shut up
okay so what is steps what is that here
we go
I'll give them the steps this is all
about reframing the past in deciding a
different future so here's the goal
here's the goal the past is a meaning
the past is not objective your memory
and your story of the past is a story
it's not actually real I'm not saying
that the events didn't occur but what
I'm saying is is your view of the events
is not the only way of viewing
those events to show as an exam as an
example yeah yes the 11 year old version
of Benjamin Hardy whose fathers whose
parents got divorced and my father
became a drug addict right when those
types of experiences happen and we have
experiences every day we give meaning to
those experiences in that meaning shapes
our identity and it shapes our view of
the world so a lot of my view of the
world was you know my parents are bad
people or whatever unit I mean which is
not actually fundamentally true that was
just my view right and so here I am now
32 years old I don't have to give the
same meanings to my former experiences
as I did when I had them I don't have to
come up with the same narratives that I
did as an 11 year old boy I can actually
with an understanding of the world with
an understanding of my father with an
understanding of people I can say you
know what I saw it one way but that's
actually not how I see it anymore
I choose you know actually you know and
I've actually gone back and I've talked
to my dad about it by the way my dad's
no longer a drug addict um he's overcome
a lot of that but I've been able to ask
him a lot of questions get a lot of
understanding and realized did I
understand completely why he made those
mistakes he was going through hell and
he went through a lot of stuff and he
had actually had a lot of baggage
himself that was unresolved and so I can
now have better context and in view that
allows me to see the situation
differently one other quick example and
this is a little bit more practical last
week I gave a talk to a group that I
really value a lot of people and you
know I'm actually getting ready to
launch the book you know and so I I was
I was giving a talk in hopes that I
would get help from some really
high-level people for the book launch
and I freaking flopped this talk I mean
I I bombed it dude I was so embarrassed
so ashamed after the talk that I wanted
to leave the group literally and I've
been in this group for three years and I
was like when you're caught in the
emotions of a moment because with
emotions there's an initial reaction so
like if if someone cuts you off on the
road or if someone punches you you know
like you're gonna have an initial
reaction but the more emotionally
developed you get the more you can
have a secondary emotions which is your
chosen response you know we call it
emotional regulation that's what I was
doing with my son with the journal look
I know what happened I know you're
feeling terrible but what should we do
about this how do you want to feel about
it you got to give it a clearer picture
right in order to and so anyways I'm
gonna just quickly go here because I
want to go back to I want to go to
future stuff but basically I was caught
up overwhelmed I was stuck in my initial
response and I was thinking I should
probably leave the group if you're
caught in an initial negative response
you get really black-and-white with your
thinking and you then become very
limited in your options so my only
options in this case was I probably
should leave the group because I'm no
longer a good member of this group
because I gave a really horrible speech
and so the only way out of that is first
off to journal about it write about your
experiences think about and then talk
about it to key people get it out so
that you can get alternative
perspectives I started talking to a few
people into saying hail if this would
happen and I honestly just don't feel
very good about the group anymore and
some people are like what you know like
why you know people would challenge my
my emotional assessment you know then
ultimately it takes courage all progress
starts by telling the truth I told the
guy who runs the group I said dude I'm
sorry first off I gave a really horrible
speech at your event also I don't know
if I can be in this group anymore
because I don't know if I'm providing
value to this group and I'm not even
sure if the group's providing value to
me I was just very open and I think that
this is a crucial key to reframing your
past is that you need to be open about
it you need to be willing to talk about
some things and also in real time talk
about it but he was like dude then it
wasn't that bad plus also that one
didn't work out very well but we've got
other options there's other ways to do
this and so I'm like I just made it made
me realize okay I was coming to some rap
decisions right and that's usually what
happens with trauma there's a negative
thing happens and you make rash
decisions and so the goal is this and
this will be the last thing I say about
the past first off the past is just a
meaning it's a memory and you can change
your memories you can change the meaning
and the emotions so rather than now and
literally this was only three or four
days ago I had a horrible three or four
days where I was caught up in my
emotions now I've proactively chosen to
view the past vadik's that episode as
that was the best meeting I've ever been
to
I didn't have to view it that way but
I'm choosing to view it that way
literally and I and I'm not saying I'm
not being naive like literally that
event happened for me not to me
and that's really how you want to view
the past is it happened for me not to me
if you can say that and you can believe
it and you can say I if I learned from
this my future's gonna be a lot better
it's like turning in the obstacle into
the way right like what Ryan holiday
would say it's choosing to look at the
past and saying I can turn this into
something better or you can say I'm
defined by this therefore I suck so
that's just step one is that you have to
choose better meanings and better story
for your past and you can do that with
anything me as an 11 old kid me last
week it's choosing a better narration in
viewing the past from a positive
perspective that it happened for you and
that is that the practical steps to do
the to perhaps journal perhaps speak to
somebody about it
are those the alternative perspective to
things neutralize the emotions right get
more information yeah you actually want
the past to be information that emotion
but yeah journaling about it writing
about it learning about it asking
questions being curious getting more
information that's what I had to do with
my dad getting more information about
the situation because the more context
you have the more empathy you'll have
the more understanding you'll have I
have empathy a lot of empathy towards my
former self I was really mad at my for
myself two days ago but now I'm like you
know what if I really think about it I
did the absolute best I could I wasn't
good enough for the task at the time but
I can but I'm not defined by where I am
right now you know what I mean and
there's still plenty of potential in
that group and in that situation if I
choose to go that way I don't have to be
defined in other words by what happened
I can still be defined by my goals and
that's actually the key is that you
don't want to be defined by the past you
want to be defined by your goals and so
and you don't want your behavior to be
predicted by your past you want your
behavior to be predicted by your future
self the person you want to be so rather
than being defined by that thing and
letting my that thing drive my behavior
I should be thinking in a more flexible
way what what is my ultimate goal
who's my future self that's the thing
that should drive how I handle this
situation which may require me to
courageously come up to the group and
say look guys I kind of flopped that
last talk but I still want help with
this launch is there anything we can do
like I could go back to being flexible
towards the goal
versus defined by the past so that's
just the thing that we need to all do
with our past as far as future self here
are the steps and this is a lot more
linear you need to think about who you
really want to be in the future your
future self is a decision you make not a
discovery you make you don't discover
your future self you decide who you want
to be and that has a lot to do with
thinking about where do you want to be
in your life like where do you want to I
think two to three years out is a great
timeframe
you know you might know beyond that like
obviously me myself as an example with
five kids
I knew five 10 years ago that I was
gonna have kids and so I had a future
self but on a very practical scale where
do you want to be in two to three years
from now what do you want your
circumstances to be who do you want like
who do you want to be in a relation ways
how do you want those relationships to
be what do you want your health to be
like what do you on your income like how
do you want your day-to-day life to be
like what do you want your focus to be
on what do you want to be doing um you
know just really clarifying your future
self once you've clarified it and I
would say through journaling and daily
morning journaling really helps you know
it's a drafting process you never
actually finished this and by the way
your current future self is based on a
few things it's based on your current
knowledge because once you learn new
things you're probably you might have
new and better goals it's also based on
your current level of confidence right
like you you know you and I may not have
the future stuff to go make a billion
dollars
you know maybe yours is in three years
maybe you have the capacity to make a
billion dollars in two years for now I
don't I I wouldn't project that right
now I think I think me and you were in
the same come so like I don't have the
confidence or the resources or the
skills to do that right now and so I
probably wouldn't have that as my future
self but as I build more confidence
through gaining more experiences through
building better relationships I can then
project out a higher level future self
but anyways once you decide your future
self you need to then change your
narrative your identity narrative rather
than being so definitive in who you are
and also overly describing your past
it becomes very powerful when you start
telling people about your future self
telling people about your goals a lot of
people say you shouldn't tell people
about your goals cuz you're gonna get
negative feedback but you should but you
need to get that if that's who you
really want to be and if that's what you
want to do
then you're actually living a lie if you
don't tell people who you're trying to
be now this isn't fake it till you make
it this isn't pretending to be your
future self because your future self is
not you they're a different person this
is saying this is where I want to go and
this is what I'm up to is what I'm
trying for that allows you to first off
believe it more because you're now
telling people who you want to be which
hits you at the subconscious level but
then when you start telling people about
your future self you will start to feel
compelled to start organizing your
behavior start acting more congruently
with your story if I started telling
people look I really want start a
podcast I start telling everyone I want
to start a podcast where I told everyone
I wanted to run a marathon if I didn't
start running they did what the Freak
why are you telling you're gonna do the
thing yeah so you start to feel
compelled to act according to your story
and therefore your behavior starts
aligning with your future self rather
than your former self and in psychology
we call it self signaling but basically
your behavior signals back to your
identity or your subconscious the type
of person you are
so this gets back to James clear you
read your behavior signals back to you
or or creates votes to the type of
person you think you are behavior
solidifies identity so when you start
telling people I want to do X Y & Z or
this is where I want to be in the future
and then you start acting that way it
really solidifies who you are and that's
how your personality gets shaped one
last thought aside from obviously like
organizing environment around your
things like that investing money into
your future identity creates an extreme
amount of commitment the more money and
obviously you can start with small
investments but for myself as an example
when I started investing money into my
goal to be a writer I got really serious
I bought a domain name back like in 2015
costing eight hundred bucks my wife was
like are you sure about this you know
but I have since made bigger and bigger
investments because when you do that
what you're doing is you're actually
saying I believe in my future self this
is who I am and I start putting money
towards it in the present in the present
I'm going to make an investment towards
that future self and that really gets
you committed like from a psychological
standpoint we call it sunk cost bias we
also call it escalation of commitment
but as you invest in things you start to
really get committed to it on an
emotional level and you identify with
the things you spend money on and so if
you're serious about something like
let's just say you're serious about
really getting in shape
get a freakin personal trainer or
something like that invest in health
products or whatever like that really
convinces your identity that this is the
door you're going it really feels like a
lot of the stuff both backward facing
and forward facing is to do with taking
the notions that we have inside of our
heads the sentiment of the person that I
was or the idea of the person that I'm
going to become and concreting them
forcing them either through linguistic
commitment or through a social
commitment or through a financial
commitment it gives them form and I feel
like at least it eat yourself yeah for
sure
your newsletter has like half a million
subs or something is that right yeah
we're completely 400,000 where can
people go to subscribe to that because
I'm sure that there'll be a lot of
people very interested in your work
after today's discussion oh cool man
thank you uh yeah if you got a Benjamin
Hardy
Benjamin Hardy calm you domain name
wasn't worth $100 man yeah seriously my
name right
I mean if I had gotten it by now it
would have been gone oh what's attitude
I'm currently in the process of like
choosing what mine's gonna be and the
some guy that makes movies in Hollywood
that has just chewed up every Kris
Williamson iteration available and I'm
like you didn't even leave a like Cole
leave a doc Cole dude come on yeah I did
he's eaten and then there's some guy
that's just got Christopher Williamson
on holding odd don't get me into it
that's the new real estate [ __ ]
parking themselves on this thing look
personality isn't permanent will be
linked in the show notes below I think
you know this is real Ground sort of
shaking scary stuff my it's gonna shake
a lot of people for sure I love it man I
love when stuff like this happens I
think it's really really cool if you've
enjoyed this discussion make sure that
you subscribe to Ben's is newsletter
personalities in permanent will be
linked in the show notes below if you
follow it through that you will be
supporting the podcast at
no extra cost to yourself where else can
people get you money on Twitter and
stuff like that yeah yeah but I mean you
can find all that stuff at Benjamin
Hardy calm
I would mostly say just get the book
personalized and permanent and go to
Benjamin hurry calm there's actually a
lot of free online courses where I break
you through the concepts in the book
this book actually has about a hundred
and fifty journal prompts throughout it
to help you reframe the past up you
really get clear on your future self it
takes you step-by-step like literally
how you can change the narrative of the
past get really clear on the narrative
of the future change your environment
change your subconscious I mean yeah
seems like a good deal to me man I mean
you know it doesn't seem like a lot but
if a book dude it's awesome a handbook
for change how fantastic look that's
what it is um thank you so much for
coming on BRR I've really really enjoyed
this it had fun there was a lot of fun
[Music]
you